my name is Miriam Oldfield I'm 18 years
old the closed loop it's basically it's
known as the artificial pancreas and
it's basically you have two devices one
is the insulin pump and the other is a
continuous glucose monitor and basically
they talk to each other and the
continuous glucose monitor that'll send
information to the pump saying you know
I'm high my blood sugar is high and then
the pump will give me insulin according
to what data it gets from the glucose
monitor it helps create a more of like a
normal life for me at least because I
don't have to constantly worry about
putting in carbohydrates into the pump
because the glucose monitor and the pump
are doing that for me
so in this particular study we are
testing what we call a closed loop
artificial pancreas
now our official pancreas is a term that
gets thrown around a lot but it's not
actually a mechanical pancreas when an
artificial pancreas is is an insulin
pump just like the kind that people with
diabetes often wear but instead of
manually determining the insulin doses
in an artificial pancreas the doses are
calculated automatically in an ongoing
fashion every minute based on the
glucose or sugar levels that is being
continuously read from a little sensor
device that the person with diabetes
wears we don't right now people with
diabetes tests of blood sugars ten to
twelve times a day there are calculating
how much its own they need they're
making adjustments in case they're
exercising or if they're sick and it all
has to be done
you have to think about it you have to
do it the systems that we have now that
we're testing will all run silently in
the background so you can just live your
life and as long as your sensors working
no long as your pump is working
everything will just happen this would
be really a total paradigm shift in how
diabetes is managed the history of
diabetes technology is that every tool
we've ever developed in diabetes has
improved health and improved medical
control of the diabetes but it's come at
the expense of increased burden so we're
constantly asked people with diabetes to
do more do more think more test more
aware more this would be the first time
that we can step up our ability to
control diabetes with less burden I'd
really like to see it on the market so
that we can get it you know however I'm
not within you know a hospital so I'd
really hope that it would be approved by
the FDA and it'll come and then everyone
can use it because I think it'll help
especially kids I know they're still
doing they're gonna continue doing tests
with close-loop though combining it with
other studies and so I'd like to
participate in those I think whatever I
can to help further the closed loop
system along to get it approved so
everyone can use it
it's really important
you